so if
you were to sell me bitcoins because
that's how it's being sold it's an
investment put your money in there
you're going to be rich it's going to go
to 100 000 it's going to go to a million
dollars
you know it's going to go to that how
would you sell me what bitcoin is
explain to me here's what bitcoin is dot
dot dot what would it be
i wouldn't i wouldn't create plumbing
when a normal person buys a house
unless they're a little bit uh
sort of a perfectionist i'll say it the
nice way
um pedantic on certain things
then they're not going to sit there
going well i need this particular
plumbing in this part of the house
and these faucets and i need ceramic um
here and i need copper there and yada
yada
now the truth of the matter is
you don't care about how your internet
connection
basically sends packets you shouldn't
care about how your money does it either
i don't want people sitting there and
going that they're some super wizard
and know these things i just want it to
be secure plumbing
i want it to sit there in the background
so that
accountants and fraud analysts can
review things
and know that it's secure i want it so
that
it's fast it's better than visa that it
costs less than paypal
that people can hold their own cash
again
which cash is disappearing that's a bad
thing
i want you to use bitcoin i don't want
you to hoard it
the the whole concept of having hoarded
money is a pathology
it's wrong if you want to save good
if you want to build good if you want to
create something
but this pathology about i'm i'm going
to get a lump of gold and hope that it
goes up in value is wrong
how about actually taking something
and building with it if
we think about going into the uh
old parables the the parable of the
servant
and i'm gonna throw this one in there
the man who had
his three servants and he gives each of
them some money
and one of them buries it under a rock
well he still has it at the end
but the one who spent it and did
something
and planted crops and and worked
i mean that's really what it's about you
don't make
anything from having a lump of money
sitting there
you make something by building things
using money is what matters
creating investing
so based on what you're saying is
bitcoin is not a
method of investment bitcoin was built
to use
to uh use meaning to purchase things
that's
cheaper than paypal not necessarily
as a method of let me buy a bunch let it
sit and then 5 10 years later i sell it
for more make more money
[Music]
exactly